okay so we'll get started
um so I hope everybody is in the right
room um this is a very boring topic as
far as I'm concerned but I've been doing
this for a while so it does get boring
talking about it but I'm hoping that
everybody's here for um a talk about
practical open Telemetry um is this
anybody's first introduction to open
Telemetry has anybody not seen or used
it oh you're in for a
treat um yeah we've got a few more
people coming in so if you can um just
move to the sides a little bit and let
people come in there's some space at the
back
there
awesome thank you so much
it's fine thank
you okay so I actually did my first talk
post pandemic here um around the same
subject um so if any of you were here um
I apologize I was um out of practice I'm
not now so hopefully this will be better
so who am I my name is Martin th I'm
first and foremost OB observability
evangelist and we'll talk a little bit
about what observability is um I'm also
a developer advocate for a company
called honeycomb who develop
observability products today I'm not
here to talk about honeycomb I'm to talk
about observability in general but also
about specifically open Telemetry and
how to use it open Telemetry has been
around for quite a
while however it's now getting to a
point where people don't want talks on
how cool it is they want talks on
actually how to use it in their
applications what should they be doing
what shouldn't they be doing and that's
really what this talk is
about so without we can't really talk
about um open Elementary Without Really
defining why it is that we're doing it
what observability actually is so
observability this is a quote from
cheres Majors um who's our CTO um who
started the movement around
observability um in software around
seven years ago um who describes it as
understanding and debugging unknown
unknowns
and the ability to ask questions that's
really what observability is about it's
not about three pillars it's not about
logs it's not about metrics it's not
about any of those things specifically
it's about asking questions it's about
the ability to ask
questions so what sort of questions well
things like what's the impact of my
change is the code that I've just wrote
being
used is this feature being
used has the time of any of my user
actions
changed cross region latencies third
parties all of that sort of stuff it's
about being able to ask those questions
how are these things
doing so why does it matter I mean we've
been writing software without this idea
for quite a while now I would assume um
I won't reveal how long I've been
writing software without this but it's
been a while so why does it matter now
um I don't know about you but as an
engineer I feel overw works I always
have done um and now we're asking
Engineers to ship more often we're
asking for daily deployments we're
asking for per commit
deployments we're asking for every hour
it's no longer in this cycle of doing
six-month deployments you know we do two
deployments a year make sure you get
your code changes
in we're asking to be done this to be
done regularly but while we're doing
that we're also being asked to write
better code like not the stuff you were
writing before no it needs to be better
now and you need to ship it more
often okay great oh but can you also
spend less time fixing books as well
like actually writing features so you
need to ship it more often make your
code better also spend time less fixing
less bugs great okay but can you also
make sure we don't have downtime as well
it's like there's all of these things
that we've been asked to do and we can't
ask engine is to do more things without
giving them better tools without giving
them the ability to do these things
better faster more
often so that introduces us to open
Telemetry what is open Telemetry we've
had Telemetry things before we've had
APM tools so application performance
monitoring tools the big vendors have
been out there doing this sort of thing
for quite a while now so what is open
Telemetry in this space now first and
formost for most open Telemetry is a
protocol it's not something we
install there are sdks but first and
foremost it's a
protocol it's how do we get Telemetry
data that we produce in our
applications to a vendor backend or an
open source backend or a back end that
you
deploy that is why open Telemetry is so
so interesting to me because it means
that we're no longer beholden to the
provider that we chose when we started
doing the
software now if you've ever tried to
move Provider from an APM tool and
you've got I don't know even just a 100
machines never mind the 1500 machines
that some people work with and they've
got an agent from said vendor installed
on all 100 machines and then you go
great we'd like to use a different
vendor and your infrastructure team go
ha oh you were
serious no we're not doing that because
reinstalling all of those agents those
proprietary things is what you need to
do to move vendors but what if you
didn't what if to be able to move
between different vendors it was three
lines of
config if all you needed to do was
change a few config lines and your new
provider gets all the same data that the
previous provider
got that is the promise of open
Telemetry and it is delivered this is in
production in lots of companies that we
work with now the other thing open
Telemetry provides in order to do this
is sdks they provide sdks inside of your
solution that produce this Telemetry in
a standardized way so that vendors or
open source Solutions can use that in
interesting
ways
open Telemetry is made up of three
primary
signals notice the word signals there
not pillars they are signals logs
metrics and
traces in the net
World traces and metrics are stable
mainly because we have activity and
meter inside of the code based from net
so yes we can use them logs the protocol
is stable but we shouldn't be using logs
anyway we'll come on to why logs are
trash
um we'll cover them for about 30 seconds
and then move
on but the protocol is stable that's the
how do we transfer between the two
systems the sdks are not which is why
when you're looking at some of these
code examples you'll see that we use the
pre-release flag to install some of the
pre-release packages that's because yes
they work yes they're in production yes
they're running at scale but
unfortunately the API might change based
on the open Telemetry
specifications
now I'm talking specifically about net
by the way so those um stability things
there are specific to
net meter um or metrics is not stable in
all languages logs is there in only
Python and net they are more coming up
but ultimately they're not
stable so what's a
trace we're talking about tracing
first because that's where I believe
everybody should be moving towards open
Telemetry is not just tracing tring but
tracing is the primary signal um that
you get value from so Trace is a thing
that is being done it's not something we
create it's not something where we go
create
Trace what we do is we create a
span and a span has a trace ID and that
is how we build up a trace because all
the spans with the same Trace ID are a
trace together but a trace itself isn't
something that that we
create so what is a span then and
talking about spans what exactly is one
you can think of it as a structured blog
of
data think about Json blob think about
any kind of blob of data you can think
about as a structured log if you really
want but it's a structured blob of data
that has some mandatory properties on it
the first one being a unique ID
something that identifies this
particular span a span ID it has a
correlation ID correlation IDs I'm
assuming most people have heard of they
have been around for a while when we
were doing logs as our primary signal um
we call that a trace
ID but it also has a
duration measured in
milliseconds it has a
duration it also has a time stamp when
this thing
started and it has the most interesting
part a causality
ID the thing that was happening at the
the time when this thing was created
essentially the parent span the thing
that happened before now having these
allows us to be able to do a trace
waterfall which is what you see on the
right on the right left my right your
left that
one and that Trace view is what allows
us to see how a request has transitioned
through our
system what caused it to happen what
happened before now you may say that we
had this before we had logs we had
correlation IDs we had time stamps and
it would transition through five
different services and I'd see all of
those sent into a centralized logging
system to that I say when was the last
time you check your time stamps on all
of your servers and your time servers
across all your different
microservices did you syn them how far
out are they quite far
normally what we do with causality ID is
essentially stamp that between all of
our services between all of the
different process
boundaries but what that it's a
structured log basically with some
mandatory properties it's basically just
a fancy
log the stickers for most of these
images by the way come and get them at
the
end so if I'm telling you that's a
span what is a log then well logs are
designed for humans they're not designed
for systems they're not designed for
aggregation they're designed for systems
we took logs and made them structured
but primarily logs are designed for
humans which means they're great for
Access logs like your access log in
engine X or is the w3c access logs
because they don't have context there's
no causality
ID they're good for audit
logs they're also really good for
debugging whether your tracing is
working or
not I wrote an entire blog post on that
there will be some links at the End by
the way um for you to pick up and and um
do some follow on
reading now ultimately most people are
doing logging wrong just ask this
guy I just um Nick is an amazing
educator he's got a talk on logging and
performance tomorrow go see it because a
lot of the things that he talks about
about optimizing performance for logging
also apply to using activity in spans so
go and have a look also look at his
YouTube um cool I mean most logs are
fine depending how much money you've got
to
burn so let's get into some
code because what we're talking about
here is how to practically do things
what are the things you should be doing
so first one is logging now you notice
here we've got the pre-release
package but it's a simple
as adding open Telemetry to your login
Builder and then we tell it where to
send that
data now here we're using the open
Telemetry line protocol which is OT LP
not
oltp because those two mean different
things and I always get them mixed up so
open Telemetry line protocol is that
protocol I was talking about about how
we transfer the the between the two
Services metrics similar thing because
metric is stable there is no pre-release
flags and the same thing we add open
cemetry as to our service collection we
say um with
tracing and then we add the OTL
exporter it's getting boring now isn't
it it's the same thing with metrics add
OTP wrong way around you get the
idea like I say these this isn't the
interesting part this is the bit that's
easy this is how easy it is to add open
Telemetry to your application you're not
telling it which vendor you're not
telling it where you're going to send it
you're literally just adding it like
this I don't know about you from years
ago when we used to start a project the
first six months of any project was
deciding which logging framework you
were going to
use and there were battles fought over
lesser
things
so once we've set up our login there are
a couple of things that are really
important to set up now we need to tell
open Telemetry what our service is
called and we do that using something
called the resource Builder because a
span is based on two different types of
attributes resource attributes which are
set at the start of a process like
startup of a ASP net cor site and
attributes that are applied to each
individual's uh to an individual spam so
here we're using configure resource I
thing I want to draw you attention tion
to here though is it's actually an
extension on ad open Telemetry for
tracing a
metrics it's not within the width
tracing
element it's specifically inside of that
which means it applies to tracing it
applies to metrics do you be careful
about the attributes that you add
globally because you can add extra
attributes like
this if you add them at this
level they will be added as labels to
every
metric there are problems with metrics
and the reason why I don't promote
metrics as much as other people is
because dimensionality of metrics is
hard when you start throwing lots and
lots of different dimensions and lots
and lots of different values in those
Dimensions metric systems tend to crawl
into a corner and say please
stop whereas traces
don't so once we've added our service we
can now add more
attributes now these don't get applied
when we create a span so from a
performance angle this is the most
efficient way to give your
traces
context but they're applied to every
span within that service once it starts
up so the reason why that's really
interesting is because we can do things
like adding the region that we deployed
our service
to if we're in
kubernetes we can add the name we can
add the deployment name the service
name we can add which specific version
of the application it is that we've got
deployed because if we're deploying
these things every day you're going to
be in a situation where you've got
multiple different versions
live that's why these things become
important okay
metrics it is incredibly
easy you'll notice is a theme throughout
what we do when we talk about this
everything is fairly simple and the
reason it's fairly simple is because
it's not
complicated I don't know how else to say
this it's a few lines of
code but it's code that you control not
a
vendor it's code that you can decide
where to put it's code that you can
decide to put context on so when we a
meter now we'll talk about how to set up
configs in a
minute in this particular example I'm
using a static class for my diagnostic
config and at the top there on that
fourth line we've got meter equals new
meter with the service
name and that's static in this
class and then we create all of our
different types of metrics for that
particular meter things like sales value
you markup histograms counters inet 8
we've now got up down counters as well
it's actually in doet 7 but Net 7
doesn't really count because it's not
LTS is it
so and then when we've created them open
Telemetry doesn't know about them so you
can create them at the top there but
until you do this bit at the bottom open
Telemetry isn't going to listen to them
it's not going to send them
anywhere it's l just going to run it um
in the background and they'll go into a
black
hole so when you create some metrics and
you don't see them check to make sure
you've added the ad meter bit at the
bottom
there now when we then go to use these
metrics because obviously we've just
defined different types of metrics at
this
point when we go to use
them it is as simple as referencing that
static class referencing the particular
type of
meter and using record for histograms
using ad for counters same for up down
counters that's
it metric's
done there isn't that much more to it
because all of the interesting things
that happen with metrics happen after
your code they happen when you put them
into a back end to do
aggregations they happen in the back end
when you start doing reporting on these
things
it's literally just that in your code
choose where you're going to put them
choose your metrics
sparingly throw labels on your metrics
but don't throw too
many otherwise your Ops team will cry
because Prometheus won't work
anymore but you can add things like that
okay instrumentation
libraries this is where we
get a level of automatic
instrumentation now this is what's going
to get you up to a point that you're
used to with an APM tool we got to a
point with APM tools where you'd install
an agent and it would give you
everything it felt like magic we just
install the thing and then we've got
pretty graphs that we can put up on a
dashboard and management think we're
doing really cool things we're really
not nobody looks at
them this is what's going to get you
there because what we've talked about is
manually creating
metrics instrumentation libraries are
language and SDK specific so these are
specific
toet they're specific to the libraries
that you have in net so when you've got
a library like SQL client or HTTP client
or grpc Services you've got aspnet core
you've got all of these different things
all of them will have an instrumentation
library that goes with it that you can
now tell open Telemetry to use or not
use it's important to to say that this
is step one this is your getting started
this is out of the out of the gates
let's just put a load of automatic stuff
on there don't stop
here so basic Microsoft stuff ASP net
core I would Hazard a guess that 80% 90%
of the people in the room are using
aspet core
you can add the packages you'll notice
they're all
pre-release do not be scared of that do
make friends with your security team so
you can explain why you're using
pre-release
packages the pre-release means that the
naming of spans and
attributes is not defined and ratified
yet that's the only
problem it's a problem we've had for
about the last two years but nobody will
fix it
until we've got that ratified those
won't be marked as stable it should
happen in about
November because we've just had all of
those schemas come into open Telemetry
and now starting to get ratified and
hopefully in November that will have all
happened and we can all move on with our
lives ASP nit core HTTP client SQL
client they're all part of the open
Cemetary name space you can add them
just with ad aspet core instrumentation
add SQL client instrumentation add HTTP
client instrumentation if you're using
Entity framework or postgress again the
same thing add npgsql and add Entity
framework you'll notice however npgsql
do Telemetry is a different namespace
and it's not pre-release because they
get to choose whether they say it's
pre-release or not and they decided not
to go
figure redis I'm presuming a lot of
people people use reddis as well um is
slightly different so reddis when we ask
for automatic instrumentation or um
instrumentation libraries it needs
access to something called The
Connection multiplexer essentially
access to the connection to add some
data for that we can use a special
extension called configure open
Telemetry Trace
provider that gets resolved when your
application starts not when you register
services so it means it can use things
from the service provider it can use
dependency
injection all of this is documented
there is a GitHub repo with all of this
in you don't need to take pictures it's
absolutely fine this is
mundane this is where it gets
interesting this is where we start to
think about what is our
context what is our context in our
application because yes most
applications you've got a database
you've got a website you've got people
hitting it you got some apis maybe it's
a bit front end maybe some microservices
happening every everybody's the same
yeah every single site's the same
everybody stores their user ID in the
right in the same place in the request
yeah everybody has the same account
object it's all accounts in the database
yeah nobody uses customer nobody uses
customer now do they your context is
important and that is where we had a
failing with
apms because they assumed so much manual
instrumentation is where we can add our
context I need to take a little bit of a
diversion to talk about span and
activity because in a land Far Far Away
known as
Seattle Microsoft designed something
called
activity and it's been in The NET
Framework since around Net
2.0 tracing has been in net for many
many many
years so it's not new when open
Telemetry came
around there was no reason for open
Telemetry to go and reinvent and create
a new
thing there is such thing as a shim that
uses span Tracer span event span links
and all of the open Telemetry technology
that you can use in net if you're
working inet every day ignore it just
use
activity okay slight run over with what
is a span or activity I'm going to use
the word activity and span
interchangeably because I don't see the
difference so please whenever I say
those two span does not mean the span
object in net which is a completely
different thing um so spanner activity
is time bound
analysis it's the idea and we talked
about what a span was it has a duration
and it has a start time a time stamp
it's about time bound
analysis we create an activity we
dispose of an activity that's our J
ation it's normally scoped to an
individual piece of work so everybody's
got that little algorithm that they've
got in their code it's the crown jewels
of their application they spent three
years building it it's got 42,000 unit
tests around it it never goes wrong so
we don't need to look at it do we but
actually what happens is the performance
of that might change depending on
inputs so an activity is how we scope
that around that piece of work where we
call the algorithm to be able to do
stuff so an activity might be a HTTP
request that comes in it might be a call
to a database it might be a call to a
third party those are things you get for
free with instrumentation libraries you
don't get them for free in your code
which is where you've got to add some
stuff spans and activities are also
about
causality so this thing happened
before it's about correlation we talked
about Trace IDs correlation IDs
and they're really
useful for understanding complex code
structures and how something takes a
path through a
platform I mean really they're just a
log but with so much
more so how do we create them the first
thing we need to create an activity is
an activity Source Now activity
sources are actually Shield um they're
actually a shell they they don't really
do anything they store a string value
basically you can create 20 different
activity sources with the same name it
really doesn't matter don't do that
create it once with a name it's
irrelevant though the name is what's
important once we've got our activity
Source we can then create activities
using a function on the source called
start activity with a name that's as
simple as it is to create a spam
diagnostic config do source. activity
now in this scenario I'm using a static
class to store my activity
Source the other way of doing this is
using dependency injection if you really
hate
yourself where you can inject a
diagnostic config my main piece of
advice is if you are doing dependency
injection like this don't try and inject
activity source
inject a custom class that contains an
activity
Source do it as a
Singleton and then use
that now there is a question I get asked
quite a lot how do I test this I have an
entire talk on that on YouTube go and
look at
it it isn't easy but it is doable and it
is really really valuable when you do
it because that isn't an interface that
you you can Mock and I'm using that in
theoc sense not theq sense because don't
use
that you can tell who in the room is up
to date with what's going on in the net
Community um okay so manually creating
spans we saw what we were doing to
manually create a span there now here's
an example bit of code um I firmly
believe this is how some um e-commerce
sites work out how to charge
people just do a random number on top of
the cat
number so the idea is here we've got a
little bit of code there that's going to
change its Performance Based on the
category ID that comes in because the
higher the category number the more
random numbers we're going to
add so how would we do that so what we
do there is we create an activity that
wraps just our for
Loop we give it a name that means
something
the name that we give it is what we call
low
cardinality essentially it's a static
string it doesn't have parameters in it
this isn't a message it's not a log
line it's low cardal it shouldn't change
the things that do change are the tags
the context so when we've put this in
we've created an
activity what we've then done is we've
added two tags the first one being the
cat ID that came in the second one being
the product price now notice the naming
Convention of the
tags we Nam space the names of our tags
using
dots that allows us in uis on the back
end depending which vendors you're using
to group these together under the common
things we then do all of our stuff we
then add a tag at the end which is our
new
price and then return out of the method
now because we're using the new using
syntax in
C what that's going to do is it's going
to dispose of the activity at the end of
the
method that's when our activity is going
to
end again it's not complicated we're not
doing anything particularly Advanced
with this this isn't Advanced C Concepts
we're using libraries that are built to
be easy to
use now what I would do though
that's that's great code I would I would
be happy to see that in people's
platforms they're adding context to
their traces that's great but we can
take this a little bit further now we
had our diagnostic config class the next
class I would advise people to make is a
diagnostic names class which contains
constants what that means is that
everybody uses the same names for their
tags now it actually suggest that people
go a step step further than this when
you're working in microservice
platforms and put this in a shared new
get
package that everybody uses so everybody
uses the same names which means you've
got shared language you've got shared
context so when you're looking at your
observability in the
background you know what you're looking
for throw throw descriptions on these
tell people what they should be putting
in them what they shouldn't be putting
in
them help your developers out
and that makes it look like something
like this I don't know about you I hate
magic strings magic strings in net make
code look horrible they make it look
unreadable it also means you can't
search through your codebase for
implementations of a
thing help your IDE out ideas have
feelings
too okay now the other thing I see quite
a lot is people wrapping the activity
class they'll create the my activity
class because it creates it it creates
an activity with very special parameters
that are unique to
us the problem with that is you're
abstracting people away from what net
brings with
activity it means that when you bring
somebody onto your team you got to
explain what all the extens or the new
classes
are activity is pretty common people can
use everywhere so just use extension
methods instead so everything is based
on
activity provide context so what we've
got here is an extension method that
will start an activity with some
TX and it's just appr proxy into source.
activity it's not a particularly
complicated one you can go a level
further with this on activity so we use
the product example and I don't actually
have a slide for
this but we used the product example
before one of the things I'd suggest
that people do is actually have an
activity extension that says set product
information which takes a product price
which takes this information and then
makes sure that all of the spans have
that information on
them okay activity versus activity
current so we've used this
code where we do creating an activity
and then we start the activity now what
that does is it creates an
activity it starts it but it
also makes activity. current which is a
special property of activity set to that
activity which means anywhere in your
code base you don't have to pass
activity
around you can just access whatever the
current activity is that's
running and add stuff to it just like
we've got there
now you do need to be
careful because that code example at the
bottom is actually the same as the one
at the
top unless another activity is created
in the
middle so in that little space in
between the start activ well it actually
says create activity that's a
bug if that said start
activity that bit at the bottom wouldn't
actually work it would add it to a new
activity in the
middle so in an example where in the
middle you're calling out to five
different methods which all create their
own
activities that doesn't mean that you're
going to use the same activity when you
get
back do be aware that if you want it to
be added to the activity you've just
created use the
activity however if you don't and you
don't care like for instance you're in a
controller method
if you're in a controller method like
that you don't have access to the
activity what you've got is activity.
current and you can say just set a tag
don't care which activity it's on just
set a
tag so just know the difference between
using the activity you've created and
using activity.
current it's up to you I can't tell you
which one's the best want to use
performance- wise they're exactly the
same it's entirely up to you which one
you want to
use but it does work over ring context
it works through all of those
things okay span
event now we're getting into the really
complicated stuff you thought it was
easy at the start you like oh I'll just
walk out I know all
this so span act span event or an
activity event it's a point in time
action something that that happen during
your span execution or your activity
execution it has its own context so it
has its own
tags very useful for say an exception
that happened in your code during the
execution of your
spam But ultimately gets then attached
to your
spam and we'll come on to why keeping
all of these things to together is
really useful at the end when we talk
about
sampling ultimately a span event is
really just a structured log but it's a
structured log that's part of your
spam so a span event has its span ID
that it's part of it also has the trace
ID it also has its own unique ID a span
event ID because you can have more than
one event on a span Tim stamp and just a
list of a bucket of attributes
so one of the other ways to use it would
be things like validation
events so if you don't want to add all
of these extra bits of information to
your current
span you can add an activity um event to
your current span we're using activity.
current here because we haven't passed
that activity
down so you can see it's pretty much the
same as we've been doing before other
than the fact that we're adding tags
when we create it now rather than adding
tags as we go
along it's also good for recording
exceptions so if an exception happens
there is an extension method in open
Telemetry that adds to activity and
allows you to do record exception pass
it the exception information it'll add
an exception message it'll add the
exception type and decompose some of
those stuff pretty much that's the
extension method stuff I was talking
about when I was saying product because
now everybody will use record exception
therefore in your back end everybody's
going to use the same
names span link I'm getting really into
it everything that we've talked about so
far is based on
parentage when you create a new P span
it's parent span I ID was the span that
was active when I did
it so sometimes that isn't the right way
to model your
observability before I came into um
doing this sort of thing for honey I
worked for a
bank we had a event driven
platform where an interest would be
acred at midnight every day for every
transaction that was
created which is fine we get a message
through
um we get a transaction created goes on
service bus a lot of systems come in do
some stuff to it great that happens
within five
minutes but then almost 24 hours later
something else
happens now it might be that that
parentage isn't the right thing and
that's where span Links come in Span
links allow us to say that our new Trace
our new Span in our new Trace relates to
another Span in another Trace
so we're not saying that this thing is a
dependency we're saying that it's linked
it might be a
dependency so we use Trace context or
span context to create these
things but it doesn't exist inside the
same trace this is how we get two traces
that we can move between the two I will
caution you on span links and span
events because not all backend vendors
support
it the most notable example for this
conference is that a your monitor
doesn't support it log analytics doesn't
support
it so it's basically an alternative to
our parent child parentage stuff that we
were talking about now we create span um
span links and this example here is
where you might want to do
this now somebody sends me a um an order
and I have to trigger an
email and then I run something
asynchronously in the
background maybe I want the sending of
the email to be related to the checkout
but maybe I
don't I don't know your context no
vendor knows your
context you are in
control of your observability journey
beyond your code when you start using
open telemetry
there are opinionated ways that some of
this work so with the new Azure service
bus libraries as an example if you able
enable the experimental
Flags a lot of these things work for
messaging and will default to
parentage but there is an option to move
it to a span link if you want
to okay
processors 18 minutes right need
to for people watching this on YouTube
this is where you go at half
speed the rest of you can do that in
your head that'd be
great okay processes so processes are
part of our open Telemetry pipeline
inside of our application which allow us
to do some interesting things with spans
when they're created and when they're
disposed and it gives us basically a
hook so that on start we can do
something on end we can do something so
we can do things like adding additional
context
it's realistically just a middleware
like you will have used for an app
builder to add use and then pass things
through your context however beware
there is a performance impact because it
runs on start it runs
synchronous if you add a thread do sleep
into a processor like that on the
on everybody who creates an activity is
going to have that
sleep before they code is executed so
you need to be really careful about what
you put in
processes that's as simple as they are
you derive them from Bas processor and
you get an Onan on end that you can
override and you can do some interesting
things like I would like the tenant ID
from my HTTP request to be on every
single span that's
created so I can add a processor that on
start goes to the headers grabs out X
tenant ID and adds that as a tag to the
activity and then I can add that using
that configure open Telemetry Tracer
provider same method that we were
talking about for reddis before because
it can use dependency
injection so we can pass it in the IH
HTTP
context now baggage if anybody has
followed me on Twitter you'll know that
this is my favorite thing to talk about
it's commonly referred to well it's
referred to by me as the foot gun you
never
wanted so baggage is the idea that you
can pass over context between your two
services to influence the tracing on
descendant
Services now the key there is
influence it's not a passing over an
attribute that will then be added to
every single trace every single span
that then comes out the back
end it's
about being able to say in the back end
something happened in the front end
that's going to say you need to add
extra
Telemetry to the back
end now there are a lot of people and a
lot of disos that add what's called a
baggage spam processor which will take
everything from baggage and add it to
your
spans honeycom is one of them I'm
sorry um but I don't recommend
it all of these stuff that we've talked
about all the trace context all of the
baggage stuff is not open Telemetry it
comes from
w3c and it comes from a standard called
Trace
context so be aware that this is
dangerous why is it
dangerous well if I set for instance
something like this
this if I set baggage. Curren do set
baggage and I set the users's account
name on there and then I make a call out
to my inventory API great the account
names come
through the problem is if that is HTTP
client there is actually
HTTP colev
corp.com they're going to get all the
account
names because open Telemetry doesn't
know the difference between one of your
internal services and your external
third
parties we can do that we can override
propagation unfortunately that's an
entire talk in its own right um but I do
have blog posts on exactly how to do
that now once we've set something in
baggage we can then in our inventory
service we can go and get the account
name out by the way everybody should
have this code in their platform
we can use that baggage data and say
well if the account name is martin.net
then I'm going to set a value that says
this is a
VIP you don't have to put that in if you
don't want suppose but you get the idea
that what I'm not doing is I'm not
adding the account name as an attribute
in the back end I'm using that to
influence the Telemetry that I build
that is why baggage was created that's
the reason why baggage exists
however a lot of people do this and they
write a span processor that we talked
about before so that on end of the span
it goes to the current baggage values
just iterates over them all and adds
them as
tags which I suppose is a way to do
it um now if you are going to do
something like this what I would
suggest is at least add a
filter and use a prefix on these baggage
items
because that baggage could be coming in
from a third party to you and if you
blindly accept all of that data and
somebody sent you over a card number a
social security number you've just added
that to your back end into all of your
observability so think about what you're
adding custom
propagation I'm going to talk a little
bit about custom propagation in terms
of
messaging so propagation itself is based
on the w3c context w3c is a standard
outside of open
Telemetry it is currently as a
recommendation not a standard I think it
takes seven years to make it through it
makes some agile projects look you know
pretty fast really don't
they but it's a an effort for us to be
able to have standards between all the
different languages with open Telemetry
propagation is automatic you don't need
to do anything if you add ASP net core
and HTTP client the auto
instrumentations that we the manual
instrumentation libraries that we talked
about at the start you will get this for
free if you are using
HTTP if you've got an aspet core website
that calls out using htcp client to
another website all of this you get for
free
however we can use propagation in
non-http
contexts and if we use the standards it
will also propagate
baggage so in Azure service bus this is
what you can do now without using the
experimental stuff within the Azure
service bu
sdks so when we create a message in
Azure service bus we new up an object
called service bus message which has
headers or properties it's called
application
properties and from there we can inject
into our application properties our
Trace
context so that message gets our Trace
context and we do that by passing in the
current context passing in any
baggage giving it the message that we
want it to inject
to and then passing a delegate over that
tells it how to set properties on them
application
properties and then we do the inverse on
the opposite side so when we get a
message we can extract the properties
from those um application properties and
we can use those to create our own
activity using that context as its
parent again repos are all
online the main thing here is knowing
that you can do it so that you know what
questions to ask to go and find the data
there isn't an exam at the end you're
not going to be quizzed on what inject
and extract
is okay got just enough time to do
something called sampling so I hope
everybody understands quantum
physics because that's where we
start sampling is very math heavy um so
I'm not going to go through that part um
I totally understand what it's all
about but we won't go through that two
types of sampling we've got head
sampling and ta
sampling head sampling happens at your
application Level tail sampling happens
inside of a centralized thing that we
like to call The
Collector and it's a way for us to
retain Trace
context
without um as much cost so it helps us
reduce our storage and our
ingest while retaining all of that
context that we that rich context that
you get from
them when we do head sampling
it looks something like this when the
request starts we make a decision are we
going to sample this data I.E keep it or
are we going to discard this particular
context now you can imagine at that
point we don't know whether this is
going to error we don't know whether
it's going to call 10 Services we don't
know whether it's going to be slow so we
have very little
information which means it's a very
coarse tool to able to make decisions on
you can make decisions on say maybe I
want to sample a small amount of my
health checks because they're not really
important to me I don't want to litter
up my tracing system with health checks
so maybe do one in a
thousand just end over a one in a
thousand but tell the back end that
there was a thousand of them so for
every one you send through say there was
a thousand which allows your back end to
be able to extrapolate what what the
actual value
was importantly it's before activities
are created that we make these
decisions it's really efficient because
it removes any performance overhead of
us actually doing any logging or any um
tracing in the back
end but the amount of information that
you can use to make a decision is very
very limited by contrast tail sampling
happens after all the spans are finished
for a particular
Trace which means we've got tons of
information to make a decision
on because it runs on a delay after that
first span has been received in our
collector it has access to all the span
data so it's got access to how many
errors happened was there a retry did it
take 5 Seconds did it take a minute did
it take 200
milliseconds which systems did it call
did it call a third party
and it can do that across the entire
Trace not just on one span it can take
into account all of the information for
all of the spans in that
Trace but it does have the
downside that it's going to delay
sending of those spans to the back
end that's an important characteristic
when you're looking at observability is
how quickly can I start asking questions
based on my
system there are platforms out there
that have a five minute SLA from you
sending it data to you being able to
receive
it now if you've ever been in an outage
5 minutes is an eternity for you to know
whether things are still working which
is why people end up going on the
website and checking themsel it's like
oh it works for me and then you realize
that you're on the internal Network and
the firewall's down so nobody can view
it the other thing is it requires an
application to send all the spans for
all the traces all the
time so you've got a lot of data exiting
your application into that so head
Samplers are pretty easy you can write
them in net that one there just takes a
random percentage of all the spans and
says I'm going to keep this one I'm not
going to keep that one the sampling
parameters are things that you get when
the um activity is created so for net it
should be but it isn't at the moment
it's broken um you should be able to do
things like
URL user agent some of the headers all
of that kind of stuff and you make a
decision am I going to keep it or am I
going to drop it and then every
descendant service that is part of this
Trace will inherit that
decision and that's all done using
something called The
Collector okay The Collector is part of
open cemetry but it's not.net
so why does it fit into this talk
the open Elementary collector is a
service written in
go and as one of my friends quite
eloquently put um
earlier Go's an awful language but all
the interesting tools are written in
it now The Collector is a service that
runs it can run in two ways it can run
as a service inside your infrastructure
as a container that everything sends
data to or it can run as a side car if
you're running kubernetes or
both one of the really cool things that
it allows is centralizing of
config so where you're sending your
observability data to might
change you might have an API key and if
you've got 1500 microservices all
sending to one Telemetry back end and
your security team comes to you and say
our key has been compromised for our
vendor I need you to go and change the
API key for where you're sending your
data and then you watch devs
cry it's like I'm not coming home
toight if you centralize your config
with the collector if you have all of
your applications all of your net
microservices all sending their data to
one collector and that collector then
forwards that data on to your backend
provider when they come to you and say
I'm really sorry I'm really sorry you're
going to have to change the config again
and you go oh it's going to take me
three weeks I'll do it at home just
don't contact
me so centralizing config is really
important it also centralizes things
like filtering and redaction it also
centralizes egress if you're in a hypers
secure environment you probably not got
access to the internet from your
microservices they have to go through
something else and when you say to them
I need all of my microservices to access
this IP address and they say great send
us a
form and you go okay is it a good Google
form and they say no back it to this
number centralizing egress allows you to
be able to put a collector at the edge
of your
network talk to your security team and
say that thing there needs to send
Telemetry to that thing there and they
go just one thing and then you're their
best
friend so centralizing that egress
allows you to be able to do it that way
it also allows you to be able to control
it over things like private link and
vpns and express routs and all of those
cool stuff
it also allows us to do filtering and
redaction of information outside of your
application what it allows you to do is
for every span that comes through
inspect the attributes and if you see 16
contiguous numbers together you're going
to redact that because that's a card
number and you shouldn't be sending it
that makes security teams
happy if you've got problems with your
security team talks and them about the
collector they'll love it but it allows
them to say filter data don't send these
spans do send these spans redact this
data keep that data these are the only
Keys you're allowed to send and do that
in one location not inside your
application the other thing it allows
you to do is enrichment one really cool
thing is if you're running
kubernetes which by the end of the year
will be the number two project from the
cloud native Computing Foundation guess
what's going to be number one open
Telemetry um it allows you to do
enrichment with kubernetes based
information
automatically so if you enable something
called The KES attributes processor in
The Collector and all of your services
are sending their data through the
collector every single one of your spans
will have a pod name it'll have the
start time of your pod it'll have the
deployment that it was part of the
replica sets that it was part of it'll
have the cluster name the node name and
you don't have to do anything and that's
why it's really cool but it will also do
tail
sampling it's a really simple service
it's configurable by you and you can do
receivers you can also if you're using
Jer at the moment inside your
applications spin up the collector send
your Jer stuff to The Collector and The
Collector will now put it in open telary
format for you really
cool and that's
me bang on time awesome um there's a QR
code there it's got some links um the
repos will be on there um I do work for
a company called honeycomb we are an
observability provider we do accept open
Cemetary data um there's a free account
that you can send 20 million events per
month every month to us for free do sign
up we did also literally write the book
on observability engineering it is free
you can download it all the links are on
the QR code all the links from all the
blog post and stuff throughout the
presentation are as well there are some
stickers at the front come take some
stickers I'm here for the rest of the
week so come and grab me have a chat I'm
open to any questions but not here
because somebody's probably going to
come on
next
for